he's also canadian it's the same thing
with like crowder
and dave rubin there's all these guys
that just didn't quite
pop and then they were like oh by the
way i love trump
well it's great you know it's actually
great that you that we brought him up
because he
no look one hour ago one hour ago he
dropped the news album
also can i just say something sure the
the rate at which he comes out with
right is too fast
the best rapper in the world can't [ __ ]
out
good songs this fast rapper in the
world's will smith
i'm not even gonna object i'm not okay
question for you then
i have one for you will smith or tom
mcdonald
you have to pick one you're a piece of
people no i just like to play these
games
hypothetically speaking if i have to
pick one mm-hmm
it has to be going will smith will smith
yeah i would too
because he's still at least like he
sucks as a rapper
but i can at least look at will smith
and go yeah i respect him
like he's been in good movies and [ __ ]
he was fresh prince and he ma
and right he actually did make a couple
good songs he did
so you can't you know what i mean like
you got to go yeah will smith man like
summertime's a banger summertime's a
banger i don't care what anybody says
summertime is is a
really good song now so tom mcdonald's
new song is called cancel i hate this i
i
hate this hold on you see the thing is
mike doesn't get the intricacies of tom
mcdonald stuff it's pretty deep
i wish tom mcdonald would get cancelled
by a truck full of ammo
mike that would be an explosive thing
don't do that mike doesn't understand
her works um
well he would be the first understand
so listen tom mcdonald okay
his new song is called canceled does he
know that cancelled only has one l
his new song is called cancelled can
somebody please call tom mcdonald and
let him know that the word canceled
has one l tom mcdonald
he didn't spell cancelled right yes one
l
i'm sure there's some really like cool
there's gotta be some cool rap reason
behind it
you know it has one l no i get it
be ready hey you know what you're ready
to take the
l right now that's the extra l because
you're about to take one
because tom mcdonald's going to drop a
flight says in the uk it has two l's oh
i'm sorry maureen
am i from the uk is tom mcdonald from
the uk or
is anyone involved in making this video
from the uk yeah that well hold on
do they spell cancel like that in canada
maybe well you don't mean that my name's
joe mcdonald i am
do they spell canceled like that in
canada because he's canadian that is
possible
okay well where is he where is he live
now he lives in america
the united states of america okay so
it's 1l
you ready
the faster i hit play the faster we get
through this
i can't be canceled there's no way that
you can stop me
fully independent there's no label who
can drop me
y'all been starting rumors let me help
you with
he's in love with donald trump y'all
can't cancel me my life is scandal free
there ain't no sponsors taking losses
20 seconds in he's already mentioned
donald trump yeah
it's these people all
all of them all of these people
are losers that saw this guy being a
winner
and tried to just tried to like
make him part of their brand they just
tried to like
suck trump's [ __ ] life force from him
my hands are clean my family and my fans
isis built that case on me for facts
because you're mad and weak
go ahead and tell the world i'm ugly and
racist
okay break my hair and i don't care
about cultural appropriation
but here's the thing tom the whole
reason that people are upset with you
or people don't like you is i don't
think you're racist
i don't think any of those things i i
don't i don't hate you it's just you're
not good
yeah and not even like i'm not even
saying as a rapper
yeah you suck like you know what i mean
you ever meet somebody like you ever go
to like a party and you're hanging out
and your friends are like oh yeah i mean
so and so and you meet a couple
and like you know you're getting along
with everybody but there's one guy and
you're like this guy
sucks like this i hung out with a.g luck
before
you know you go to you're like god man
this dude really sucks i don't know what
it is
but everything about this guy sucks it's
not even the rapping it's not your
by the way i know dudes i'm friends with
dudes
that have face tattoos and gold teeth
and [ __ ] braids and [ __ ]
like i'm friends with white i do not the
braid guy
okay but like yeah ben has a face tattoo
now and he wears a grill
does he really yeah he doesn't give a
[ __ ] but like good for him
but there's you know people i know that
i you know people can vouch for him and
go yeah he's kind of a hood rat
but like you just suck dude it's not
even your
what you think is your original style or
the fact that you like
i like trump but you suck dude you just
suck
after the ghetto lived in the ghetto
there's no caucasians
and still i loved every single one of my
neighbors how's a man
say i'm click bait if he gonna use this
face to get clicks on his page i'll
hypocrites up
me but i ain't tripping bout these
bullies that ain't sixth grade
go ahead and diss me trying to sell a
couple mixtapes
i'm not afraid take my face in my name
paste it on the front page i'm already
famous
yeah it does seem kind of a few years
old right he's got that like
again i always say he's trying to
emulate
the the like middle of his career eminem
like the eminem show and marshall
mathers curtain call he wants that like
dark like like okay steals his flow the
it's the same kind of production
[Music]
this whole thing he wanted to be eminem
so bad growing up
or claiming he'll take it away my crying
waking right my rhymes different you
could try to quantify the fine limits as
a dying gimmick and denying winning this
is purifier this ain't white privilege
i do what i want get all the gucci and
louis vuitton out of my closet out of my
crib i do not want it that is for kids
that is for rappers to ask you to
produce their beats for free pretending
i mind like they rich
i am not playing it safe i said what i
said it is what it is
he's not gonna say sorry and i i hate
this
this this like i'm in on something man
like i'm tuned into the universe bro i'm
so woke
like i gotta [ __ ] drop this knowledge
on you people like
you're an [ __ ] if you did if you'd if
you hadn't
figured out this trump grift you'd be
moonlighting like at night you'd be one
of those guys that works at a kangaroo
gas station
and it wouldn't be even they wouldn't
even have you on day shift because
what just out of all the gas stations
you pick kangaroo and i
it actually i know why because you're
picturing every kangaroo right now and
you're going
bad neighborhood bad neighborhood bad
neighborhood
it's kangaroos are they are the checkers
of gas stations
you know you're in a bad neighborhood
when there's a kangaroo yeah he'd be
selling newports through bulletproof
glass
if he wasn't after 10 p.m they only open
up the little
side window and that's what i mean he'd
be the night guy yeah and he'd be going
hey dog yo my baby mom yo she about to
have another kid yo and like
you know i was hoping that i could get
like some day shifts while the kids is
at school and they're like
i cannot allow customers to see you
during the day
you can sell the you can be here at
night when the blacks are sleeping
outside and asking for money in the
parking lot
yeah people people know kangaroos
somebody's saying oh yeah that's the
place you buy bad lighters and lucy's
yeah
because you're not gonna have your
indian nephew go out
at night in those neighborhoods and take
the garbage out
so you hire a white guy like this who's
just complete garbage
and then like that's the guy that at
night you see like sneaking a smoke
while he runs out to do the garbage real
quick and you're like you're doing the
garbage at three in the morning like
they really don't care about you they're
gonna kill you
go yes and change the channel you're on
youtube
i really can't do that gokart says merch
liked bone thugs that's how
he was excuse me sir i like
bone thugs okay and they don't make you
all right the
part where i put dicks in my butt is
what makes me that's probably the
thing i like bone thugs too so you can
say whatever you want but i'm always
also a fan of
well i'm sorry meet you at the
crossroads thuggish ruggish
they did songs with tupac and with
biggie yeah the love of money is a great
song
even though easy ruined it yeah no he
did with his eight with his
well that too his [ __ ] his verse on
that song was it
it was really bad
what an outlaw this guy is our clip
channel leaps out the leafs out stuff
too so we stay monetized
does they luck bleep out [ __ ] well
i would understand the [ __ ] no no no no
no here's here's how it works here's how
it works so check this out
the first 30 seconds of a video
can't have [ __ ] or any curse after 30
seconds
so if there's something in the first 30
seconds like that he will bleep it out
but after that it doesn't matter
now there's certain words you cannot say
if you want to see you can't say
uh you can't say that what if i'm
talking about getting work done on my
car
i guarantee you if you were to say
training you were talking about your car
it would get that it would it wouldn't
get that full monetization and get the
half thing and then you would have to
appeal it
then after somebody checked it they
would i'm gonna do an entire video
that's like really like drenched in
sarcasm
yeah where i'm talking about my car's
training
what is this guy's like not just him but
people like him who's trying to cancel
him
nobody nobody even knows he exists
nobody cares no nobody has ever tried to
cancel tom mcdonald
he was on fox news yesterday nope like
when has anybody ever said we need to
shut this gate like
do you understand there's ones that
people on the left don't touch because
you're just so god damn cringe that
they're like nah let that guy go it's
hilarious
nobody's trying to stop you thank you
both
you might not consider yourself someone
who cares about a rap song that's
climbing the charts but it is a pretty
interesting culture
get ready this is exactly the time i
want to talk about his fan base
if you're a rapper that's being promoted
by fox news i would think
that should be your death sentence right
for being in the rap game
moment when the tune is called fake woke
it attacks cancel culture and it
questions the black lives matter
movement the exclusive interview
no you have to watch this this is really
cool why aren't you watching it it's
cool
i can't i can't like that are you sure
this isn't
news max no this is fox news ah i
i this is a show that comes on right
before tucker
this is get oh god i'm getting the worst
douche chills
listening to this white woman describe
how cool the song oh god you
you don't want to miss next
in just a couple of days the viral hit
is called fake
woke canadian rapper tom mcdonald serves
up a controversial take on cancel
culture
and fake woke was the song that he
quotes ben shapiro facts don't care
about your feelings remember we played
that one
more headlines 24 7 reporter carly
shimkus has just spoken with tom
mcdonald exclusively
hi carly hey martha yeah that's right it
was a very interesting interview and you
know it's common for musicians to
release politically charged songs these
days
but you've probably never heard one
quite like this before
rapper tom mcdonald rails against cancel
culture and censorship
culture in his new song titled fox news
like
hiding these white women in like a
bunker under the fox news building it's
a cloning facility
i mean as long as we're going to keep
women that look like this in the gene
pool
i'm good with it for bowl performer the
weekend and grammy winner ed
sheeran mcdonald believes his music is
popular because he is willing to scream
what others would never say out loud
he says what you you know what he does
he says what you're thinking
i was just about screaming my truth at
the top of my lungs and sort of
uh there's this performative wokeness
that's going on in society today
and i think it was just important to
point some fingers at the
hypocrisy and the
the way that the world is changing um
not for the better
now the 32 year old is no stranger to
tackling hot button issues and a track
released
last year titled people are stupid he
made his feelings on abortion clear
wondering why
some don't consider a heartbeat a sign
of life wow man
that's it he's wrapping memes he's
rapping
he just raps memes he's rapping right
wing memes yes
oh god and like it's not like
i know some of you guys are going to go
at least his message is good there's
there's a single abortion that's going
to be prevented
because somebody heard a tom mcdonald
song and went oh my god he's right
you're right it does have a heartbeat
[ __ ] man i didn't think about that
until tom mcdonald said something about
abortion sorry tell me how this works
bacteria is life on mars but a heartbeat
isn't life on earth
that i i'm not kidding you i'm i'm sorry
calm down here
i have actually seen a boomer why
my mom post that exact meme yeah he
takes me on facebook
but that exact one that exact bacteria's
life on mars but
oh my god but this is like you realize
that this is just we're watching
idiocracy play out
yeah and you know he knows that those
memes
attract these dummies and he knows that
if you can wrap those those memes people
are like
whoa i saw that meme dude i relate to
this guy like
it's i swear to god dude people are
we're done we're done we're we're we're
a couple of years away from having
carl's jr atms
weird in another song he discussed black
lives matter calling it a valuable movie
calling them a bunch of
then i would have turned me around if he
just called black lives matter a bunch
of n-words
she hates this by the way oh yeah
but she's a young reporter she's gotta
do what they give her she's the bee girl
on the b
show on the b [ __ ] you know schedule
but you can tell she just did she was
given this
she had to go do it and now she's like
yeah and he's you know
really had some cool things to say you
could just tell she's like god damn it
why can't i be i these [ __ ]
if i don't get to go to iran and film
some of these dead
kids in a couple of years i'm going to
be so [ __ ] angry
lifeless it's lifeless eyes there's
nothing behind them once he does this
i i've put in three times to be part of
the iranian uh
uh you know the guys that got iran and
we'll see
it's probably one of those where she
walks up she goes look i actually have
i've been doing i've been working on
this a month i have proof of corruption
in the government
that's cool you're doing the tom
mcdonald story you know when i went to
college right i
uncovered embezzlement going on right
into college at the newspaper but look
how woke this rapper is go go go pander
you go do a zoom meeting with tom
mcdonald go you're on you're on at 3 p.m
the zoom meeting with tom mcdonald do
you know how much i would dread that
like coming into work that day and
you're like hey what's up tom
cool man
that's all i imagined i imagined her
having these big scoops and them just
[ __ ] going that's great that's really
cool
hey um so today you're gonna go to a
carnival and you're gonna talk about
somebody that they tried to cancel at a
ball pit
hey did you know that uh they just
locked up that uh
the guy that putin has beef with in
russia and they're probably just going
to execute him in some black site prison
that's awesome listen
we got uh we got diamond and silk on
zoom
four o'clock with the hodge twins well
it's just diamond in one of the hodges
it's one
one it's silk and then one of the hot
chicks i don't know their name the one
on the right
jerry hodge which one's the one i don't
know their names what's the hodge which
names i don't know them
we're gonna have the uh hodge twins and
diamond and still come in today they're
gonna be dressing like the crows from
dumbo and we need you to play the piano
for a musical number and she's like can
i can i
i'll go to newsmax it's fine i'll go to
newsmax
and disavow the my pillow guy i guess
well i'll see your elephant fly
dress up like the crows from dumbbells
she's just like okay man
it's whatever oh they're kevin and keith
hodge that's their names there we go who
gives a [ __ ]
somebody said roots calhoun said jamal
and tyrone
so kevin and keith um keith is the black
one
movement but adding all lives matter
isn't racist or stupid
supporters call his fans refreshing but
i love her
i love this woman now not just because
she's hot but she you could just see the
and i'll tell you why i love her because
she hates it
and honestly to somebody with an
untrained eye she's doing a very good
job of pretending she doesn't hate it i
can just pick up that she hates it
but she this girl is a [ __ ] pro she's
like
yeah you really had some cool stuff to
say but it's all in her eyes
your eyes can't lie like she's doing a
great job of lying but the eyes are
please kill me and she's pretending he's
cool but you know she dates guys that
look like patrick bateman
yeah no they all look like total like
blonde chads yeah like cleft chins
they all look like uh harvey dent yes
she's out on dates with harvey dent
and she's literally having her third
drink going oh my god and then tomorrow
i have to talk to candace owens
can you talk to that dumb [ __ ] ugh i
hate this i hate you know what you know
i make 26 000 a year i don't need this
i have i have two hundred thousand
dollars in student debt and this is what
i'm doing seriously
accused him of racism i had to suck
roger ailes dick for this
homophobia one twitter user writing um
if someone listens to tom mcdonald cut
them off completely
another tweeting if you like tom
mcdonald you gotta be racist
okay but these are first of all tweets
with no likes
tweets with no like you found two tweets
like we now let's think about the tweets
that have been sent about trump
let's think about the tweets that have
been sent about like like famous like
richard spencer types right like kill
these people [ __ ] them
it's ruined their lives i think that
person should be
[ __ ] to death by storm troopers you
know like
and that was just merch yeah and that's
just me this is
pretty looking like i don't know dawg
that sounds pretty racist to me okay and
how do we know
let's be honest how many of these are
tom mcdonald alts
or or not even for fox people
i know who i am my friends and my family
know who i am my fans know who i am
apparently he's a big fan of care bears
i hate him so everything about him is
enraging and if i see something on tv
i change the channel if i'm reading
something i don't like i close the book
whoa whoa he could read
like i don't try to call the radio
station
and and call and call the people who
were on tv
names and try to cancel them wow you
could actually tell how stupid he is
when he talks
he's pretty dumb i mean you can
look at his face and go he's not a smart
man
no because what's your like honestly
even if you are cool rapper guy
eminem didn't get all these face tattoos
and [ __ ] like all these other guys that
are faint like
most people still think like into the
future
like you're gonna look like a really sad
old man there isn't gonna be a cool old
man with face tattoos
that's not going to be a thing in our
generation there's not going to be any
old guys that you see with tattoos like
that on their phone you're going to go
that guy is awesome you understand we're
all going to a hospice someday
that's the [ __ ] end game for most of
us and don't you want to at least be an
old guy that looks like an old tom
mcdonald normal
old guy you know i don't mind like a you
know like
the only tattoos that look cool on old
guys are the ones like the old old guys
where you could tell they were in the
military
and it was like world war ii when they
got its anchor on their arms or like a
lady
yeah and you got a sexy lady on the air
really badly drawn yeah
that you can tell he probably had that
done with like
pen ink and a [ __ ] hot needle with a
lighter done in the [ __ ] battlefield
so like that's cool but like these guys
are gonna look like
[ __ ]